our Parliament's have a bracelet and ice
worth constituency 7th May 2015
Declaration result poll I the
undersigned being the returning officer
the election and on Thursday December
May 2015
due to their might've noticed but the
number of votes for each Saturday at the
election is as follows
Joseph Gerald known as Joe Liberal
Democrats 2305 Cadbury Ruth of Margaret
known as Harry Ruth Labour Party 25,000
and 96
Goldsmith Daniel Charles Green Party
2120 Kendra and Richard UK Independence
Party 3203 McLeod Mary the Conservative
Party candidate 24,000
don't repeat back because I opened at
the end of that 24601 you projected
votes want to miss a lot now I'm voting
for the wrong day writing on over to the
post will be attempted by two unmarked
Aurora 1701 total rejected both 157 that
total votes 7,500 and I hereby declare
has been elected
quietly to calculate Ruth's cavalry to
say a few words
thank you they faxed it to you Mary Hart
believe and all of your team here
tonight and all of the polling staff
who've worked such a mundane yesterday I
also like to thank that piece the police
for their own spike the many schools and
organizations who gave up their premises
for the day and for all the authorities
who enabled the smooth running of this
election
this is my eighth time at a
parliamentary election count in this
building but my first as a candidate so
I know how hard so many people want work
to make our democracy work I'd like to
thank my amazingly hard-working agents
James with us
many many people who've played their
part in the labor can made in Britain
and izalith I anna-lena party are
eternally grateful to people who have
put someone who put their lives on hold
for weeks to work for this campaign I
thank you very much special gratitude
goes to my husband Nick and their
patience tolerance love and support know
no bounds and it's mum along with my
late dad who I have to thank from
sinning the values of social justice
that are so important political
disagreements
I would also also like to pay tribute to
mary mcleod and the work she's done in
the recognizably constituency
I will be continuing many of them and I
hope many normal but thank you man
although forward thought this has been a
clean and fair campaign and I commend
all the qualities of their homework on
it having represented local people for
two decades on the council I most of all
want to thank the people of breathalyzer
worth for now giving me an opportunity
to speak up for them in Parliament I
stood on a clear leg a platform I stood
for policies that favor poor working
families and men that don't benefit a
rich and eat I stood for stronger NHS
more nurses and GPS I stood for an
educational service where every child is
taught by a properly qualified teacher
and that we would want to cut tuition
fees for students I stood for more
affordable family housing and action to
tackle ripoff friends I stood for an
immigration policy based on fairness and
not on racism I stood through policies
when hard work is rewarded with high
skill high wage jobs for an economy
built on strong and secure foundations
where we balance suppose I'm proud that
this is what the people of this
constituency have voted for so thank you
to the voter to ventolin izalith I look
forward to serving all of you however
you voted in this election thank you
very much